combien c'est facile pour une femme de
douter d'elle moi j'avais envie de
comprendre pourquoi on est tous les
défis dans la vue et on enseigne qu'on a
le plus besoin d'apprendre
je veux vous parler mon plus gros défi
celui de me sentir capable est valable
tout au long de ma vie
j'expérimente et les situations au
moment de confiance et j'estime en soit
pour paralyser
ça fait plus de trente ans je suis ce
marché du travail et ça fait trente ans
que je devais les compétences pourtant
j'ai réalisé beaucoup de projets j'ai
reçu des retours extraordinaire sur les
résultats alors comment durant toutes
ces années avec au total et d'atouts je
me suis toujours sentie incompétent
jamal ôta jamais s'y prête
je le suis j'ai beaucoup de charisme
j'ai une personnalité qui fut sien des
relations interpersonnelles qui sont
riches nous le sens partagé la vie à dan
et pour un fluide oral traumatisme j'ai
étudié dans les bonnes conditions
mes parents n'ont jamais fait de
l'inhalation de genre envers moi au
contrat toujours encouragé à faire tout
ce dont j'étais capable
tout ce dont j'avais envie alors pour
coup je me sa botte
un jour j'en ai eu assez j'ai vraiment
eu besoin de comprendre comment j'en
avais fait pour l'arrivée remettre dans
un tel état au départ j'ai senti que ma
vie est remplie de doutes
j'ai compris que les bandes 2 ce qui
nous permet de nous remettre en question
et de faire les meilleurs mais analyse
de la situation et au style est mort et
d'août ce qui nous paralyse et qui nous
détruisent est-ce que derrière ces deux
marins se cacherait
un manque de confiance en soi ou une
faible estime de soi un clic et j'ai
cherché à comprendre la différence entre
les deux le manque de confiance et quand
je le répète je crois capable je pars là
bas j'y arriverais jamais la confiance
en soi
donc c'est combien je le considère
capable le manque d steam c'est quand je
me répète jour programme chose je suis
vraiment pas important
je suis vraiment ne font entendre
je me promène alors l'estiment de soi
c'est combien je me considère valables
et que la confiance en soi mesure la
capacité à bien faire les choses plus
j'expérimente stabilité plus choquant je
me sens compétent et en sécurité
l'estiment de soi se mesurent ma
validité c'est conforme que je ressens
quand je me sens en accord avec mes
valeurs mes besoins et mes émotions plus
je me sens en sécurité
puis j'ai confiance en moi plus je suis
fidèle à mes valeurs
meyer mon estime de moi la bonne
nouvelle c'est que jj pouvoir sommet
d'août
c'est excellent parce que ça veut dire
que je peux changer les choses et non
seulement je peux changer les choses je
peux les changer à n'importe quel âge
puis il donne votre temps pour moi mais
il fallait encore que je comprenne
j'avais besoin de comprendre pourquoi je
me sentais insécure parlera par les
opinions pourquoi j'avais par des
conséquences de mes décisions
pourquoi chanter besoin demandez un père
lucien à quelqu'un pourquoi ce vide
rempli
ici dans mon monde comment réparer cette
déconnexion entre mon vécu et mes
expériences
est ce que ces questions mais exil
chemin suivent pas ce qu'on aurait dit
que c'était passé dans ma petite vie
ordinaire arrivait pas à justifier ce
niveau d'insécurité il fallait avoir
quelque chose d'autre quelque chose qui
venait d'ailleurs alors je concilie
l'histoire des femmes avait peut-être
quelque chose
un rôle à jouer car mon histoire
personnelle j'ai commencé à chercher les
femmes sont violentées depuis le début
l'histoire de mètres de l'humanité les
balbutiements encore aujourd'hui pour se
rappeler que le mariage sont en régime
c'est un conte droit de passation de
biens entre un père et un autre homme
il ya aussi plein d'exemples dans notre
histoire canadienne avant 1909 enlevé
une femme de plus de 16 ans ce talent
égal avant 1929 les femmes n'étaient pas
considérés comme des personnes au sens
légal savent à peu près moins 100 ans en
1938 les femmes en feuilles droite
s'inscrire au lierse qui se demander la
permission à leur manière ils celui ci
pouvait l'empêcher de travailler c'est
juste en 1965 que les femmes ont pu
ouvrir un compte bancaire et exercer une
activité professionnelle sans
consentement de leur mari que ça fait
juste cinquante trois un peu plus proche
de moi je vole amis en 1972 quelque
obligé d'écrire un président grand brun
nas canadienne pour qu'une carte de
crédit sont émises à son nom et non à
faire de son mari ça fait quarante six
heures avant 1983
les forces policières de l'ontario
n'étaient pas tenus de porter des
a sion dans le code de violences
conjugales
ça veut dire que les hommes pouvaient
battent leurs femmes sans encourir
aucune sanction
ça ça fait juste 38 38 ans donc si on
regarde l'histoire ressemble des femmes
dans l'évolution du magit et 100 ans
c'est beaucoup
50 ans c'est hier j'ai pas vécu à cette
époque j'ai pas subi cette
discrimination mais je le suis quand
même demandé est ce que ça se pourrait
qu'on subit ce passé collectif que
l'histoire des femmes se soient
infiltrés dans notre inconscient il nous
affecte encore aujourd'hui c'est comme
si une mémoire qui se veut protectrice
ce légal 2 à l'autre une empreinte pro
mathis qui se manifestent de divers
processus physiologiques psychologiques
et sociaux une empreinte roma est ce que
ces cellules transports tous ses bagages
vieux de plusieurs décennies et en
conséquence avec plein de confiance en
soi une autre estime de soi oui je pense
une aube cichy se souvient se souvient
notre histoire collective et qu'elle en
dit plus long beaucoup plus lent sur les
insécurités que mon histoire personnelle
donc chacune de nous on doit réfléchir à
comment l'histoire collective s'est
infiltré dans notre histoire personnelle
et moi si elle nous affecte
ils sont allés tous différentes
on a tous nos propre chemin alors
comment une banque viable quel sac de
sable ou peut laisser passer il est
qu'elle doit être conservée pour se
sentir en confiance et en sécurité
je me suis demandé qui allait redonner
courage
face aux délestages c'est m
la petite josé s'est elle a du courage
de devenir l mois l'arrivée mais 50 ans
avec une jambe de date de péremption
savent ce que j'ai entendu la sonnette m
je me suis souvent dit que l'urgence
d'agir vient en tournée l'année bétail
et d'ailleurs j'ai fait parler d'elle
dans cet état d'esprit
j'étais tanné de sable me laisser
diriger par ce vilain coty en somme
qu'il répétait toujours la même cassette
dans ma tête
tu en fais jamais ainsi et maintenant
voilà père oublie ça ne va jamais et
même pas ses vols je vous laisse je
crois que je vais raconter à mon sujet
qu'il faisait en souffrir j'ai eu envie
de me dire que je mérite mieux que je
suis assis antienne complète
j'ai envie choisir de croire ce que les
autres pensent de moi et je savais qu'il
manquait le mans en mes capacités et à
mon estime de moi mais j'avais surtout
j'étais voit la seule femme
on savait que c'était comme si la barre
était non seulement tard dans son
discours aux jeunes diplômés
schauble la chef d'escouade à son chef
pour leurs actes posez vous la question
de ce que vous feriez si vous n'aviez
pas par et faites-le études avez tout
mon courage et ma fragilité que je suis
monté sur cette scène aujourd'hui parce
que je crois en étant vulnérables et en
partageant ses biens qui on arrive à se
transformer et en effet d'autres
passages quels sont les chemins de givry
j'ai pris le chemin encore c'est lui qui
m'a indiqué qu'est ce que j'avais à
prendre
qu'est-ce que je
on prend je vis depuis des années avec
une déviation de la colonne vertébrale
de nature idiopathique katie diagnostic
m en essence le monde du bâti ça veut
dire symptômes dont on connaît pour la
cause que j'y vois envie d'explorer
cette cause ailleurs que dans quelques
jours de la médecine les sommes mises à
ce tube in pointe
est-ce que les formes pensée avait
quelque chose à y avoir je n'en ai
appris à respirer avec le pilates le
yoga la méditation la respiration
alchimique conscient pour défaire toutes
ces boules des moissons qui viennent
presque partout encore oui j'ai pris la
voie des émotions
la boule de chorales j'avais pris à la
gorge ça venait peut-être de la
déconnexion entre la perception ma main
puisque les hôtes avec nous j'ai posés
l'un des exercices de parts dans la
montagne
mes enfants m'ont enseigné ce dont
j'avais besoin d'apprendre pour devenir
celle çi
je leur en suis extrêmement
reconnaissante
merci l'homme
j'avance maintenant à ma vie avec
beaucoup plus d'amour pour clichy et
comme par magie
j'ai plus d'amour à offrir j'ai pris le
chemin de ma sexualité
j'ai pris conscience et parce que vous
avez le portugais valeur et ça affecte
les croyances
parce que j'avais pas trouvé réponse
satisfaisante en religion mon enfance
j'ai cherché à l'ouvrir macaques cette
quête de spiritualité qui ferment qui
évolue jour après jour j'ai fait
quotidiennement cet exercice danic mans
avec moi même avec mon essence avec qui
je suis
ces chemins non de donner une nouvelle
perspective sur mon passé et sur la
situation actuelle je le vois à mon
corps la déviation de la pologne l'a
fait brasser région matin à dresser mons
tout fait de plus en plus profond et
réunifiant j'ai compris quelque élection
forme que prennent nos sentiments de nos
régimes sunnites et nous freine dans mon
ambition
je suis plein sur bien fait ctif jdd sur
ce virus mais sans renier mon passé je
pu importer poids il savez vous quoi que
les congés telle arme
c'est à partir de l'argent big fix me
sors de ta blessure mais force est de
ville à partir de qui je suis vraiment
est-ce que c'est parfait maintenant est
ce que c'est important que ce soit
parfait
la sauce qui est important c'est
d'avancer de rester fidèle à qui on est
c'est même une ambition de l'avant et
foncer prendre notre place c'est un
exploit rame en hiver que j'ai compris
qu'une femme que le changement en
changeant son monde
alors si de manière générale j'ai pris
le risque de partager ce jeudi
ce que je crois sincèrement que nous
devons nous ouvrir les unes aux autres
pour nous pour nous aider à avancer et
on pourrait pas de plus en plus
nombreuses à faire parce qu'on est un
brin entendre on est nombreux à
s'activer et le soutien et le plus en
plus présente
le parti n'est pas mais pour justin
négatif oui les nouveaux acquis sont
fragiles mais ils ont fait avancer la
conscience mais on est juste à penser à
la libération sexuelle des années 60 à
la révolution féminine les années 70 les
working girl des années 80 quand on y
pense
ses chansons sont vraiment nouveau cette
nouvelle liberté
si comme certains cas à petite enfance
dans l'est dans une version on a réussi
à passer plein de choses et pas combiner
en continu entendez vous les silences
qui se brisent achats gi joe voyez vous
les hommes qui nous dit seulement belize
pour nous appuyer et qui confrontent
ceux qui nous accusent la santé vous la
poussez d'angola d'assaut les bons
basiques des femmes qui arrivent
partout sont parfaits dans la basse le
point basculer là il ya des graphiques
changement en société nos organisations
et aux communautés
comment prendre place dans des oeuvres
comme fin dans cet environnement en
mutation et créer des changements qui
nous ressemble dans son reer en ferr une
bonne nouvelle avec sookie une rencontre
au cours de l'histoire la culture du
monde ces réformes ont changé lorsque
seulement dix à quinze constant de la
population avait un délire des nouvelles
idées monge envie d'y croire comme des
rangs juniors
michel important qui nous laisse sa
femme ses neveux par le côté plus foncée
et je serai en parlant français
c'est enrichissant force du femina you
compétences 21e siècle que j'étais
inscrit
l'amérique aurait inventé n'aura pas une
façon de communiquer en privé en société
et dans le monde professionnel et
oublier suspect révocation et de
transition pour la transparence la
confiance et la sécurité
on est entré dans une ère de virtualité
d'intelligence artificielle il de
globalité ont réussi en pluie dans une
ère de collaboration et de co-création
j'ai une proposition à faire danser même
temps changeant le mode de
fonctionnement est érigée du masculin
je n'ai pas forcément les compétences du
féminin en euros des bancs
sachez on sait tous que le parti assure
plus grand nico tu remportes qu'elles
ont plus efficaces et les yeux dans les
berges sont confiés on a besoin de viser
lizio de travailler en inclusion de
penser comme les designers de travailler
avec l'intelligence collective au réseau
des problèmes sont de plus en plus
complexes pour mettre de l'avant mais
alors plus humaines de l'otan cité et
plus d'amauri il faut se soucier du
bien-être personnel du bien être
collectif
il faut utiliser les compétences
d'intelligence émotionnelle est super
important a ajouté didier collectif
féminin à l'intelligence artificielle
les organisations doivent réagir les
employés des gestionnaires les
dirigeants qui seront portés en eau
s'est alors développé une éthique
adéquat pour un v6 modifié c'est sur
cette transformation est région beaucoup
de travail souhaite le féminin ça existe
tant pour l'homme que pour la femme
c'était mon temps pour ainsi de porter
ce prix versera pour équilibrer la
balance entre ces deux forces
c'est une opportunité incroyable pour
les femmes de faire une différence et de
montrer qu'on le faire les choses
autrement est ce que le féminin serait
le super pouvoir dans lesquelles puiser
pour changer le monde le faisait
demander mais qu'est ce que tu veux dire
par
rimini je veux vous parler de
l'inclusion de la pensée holistique de
la créativité de l'empathie la
sensibilité tout ça la vulnérabilité et
de la force des émotions à quoi pourrait
ressembler un monde où on aurait envie
le che féminin assumer dans son lit les
athlètes et le chiffre n'est l'otan
conférencière janie duquette nous fait
une bonne militants une propose ceci
dénommé richie plus ouvert
créatif empathique rassembleur porter
dans la collaboration de reportages ont
bu le sang quand on a rien à perdre les
bandits pour toutes celles qui portent
ces efforts semblent pour qui ces propos
raisin
c'est ainsi mer est français on a tout
ce qu'ils font pour la faire maintenant
changer l'idée à partir de qui nous
sommes
c'est simplement une personne est ce
plutôt chaud
[Applaudissements]